remembering the Schumann declaration on
the 9th of May in 1950 that laid the
foundations for a united Europe the
theme for this year's opened doors of
the parliament was also one of the EU
institutions dedicated 2015 to
international development joining mep s
to highlight the need for dignity of
women the recipient of this year's
sakharov prize dr. Denis mukwege a the
Congolese gynecologist affectionately
called the man who heals women the EU
spend sixty billion euros and
development every year when the frank
discussion court came for more action
this European Union and especially its
member states are not living up to the
promise yet that was given in 1972 every
year spend 0.7 percent on Development
Corporation just outside the doors the
chamber political families had also set
up camp 1 stand even pointed to the need
to act on a recent disaster over at the
liberal democrats won MEP was busy
having his picture taken what is
important for instance is two hands are
there questions a lot of people are
questioning me about our salary about
what we are doing here about the fact
that we are working hard or not but
outside was where the real party was at
tens of stands set up by the various
NGOs and development partners line the
main concourse of the Parliament aside
from all of this there was also a
graffiti wall what was a link here to
Europe day our culture graffiti artist
is more accepted the last year's it's
another generation I think also and the
street art is more more and more except
like in contemporary art as the music
kept playing around
I'm dead leaves commitment to those most
in need as a beat that must pay on